Jonah Yu: 但其实不是的。
Jonah Yu: 第一世纪有非常非常多的人，是亲眼见过耶稣亲耳听过耶稣讲道理，那
Jonah Yu: 今天我们看到的这个经文能够给我们一点。
Jonah Yu: 一点感受就是当时耶稣的影响力有多大。
Jonah Yu: 而且除了圣经以外，在第一世纪的很多历史学家的。
Jonah Yu: 记载著作。
Jonah Yu: 在这个历史研究当中，他们是像当时的世界述说过耶稣真实的事情，
Jonah Yu: 它不是从一个文学的角度也不是从一个哲学的角度，更不是从故事的角度，它们是从历史的角度，
Jonah Yu: 有若干位重要的历史学家都对于耶稣的当时的影响力
Jonah Yu: 写下过很多的记载。
Jonah Yu: 如果有兴趣的话，你可以上网查一查。
Jonah Yu: 当然更具影响力的是耶稣所带的这些门徒。
Jonah Yu: 如果我们知道有一幅画著最后的晚餐，
Jonah Yu: 那幅画。现在在米兰的那幅画就是画在米兰，意大利米兰的一个小教堂的地下室，
Jonah Yu: 那个画画的就是耶稣和12个门徒，左边，右边六个坐在一个桌子上吃晚饭，那如果没有机会，将来会读到那个故事，
Jonah Yu: 那这个12个人，就是今天我们读的这个圣经里面，
Jonah Yu: 后面讲到了这12个人，这12个人
Jonah Yu: 在第一世纪是非常有影响力的，对其中有一个叫多玛，这个人最后
Jonah Yu: 死在印度，
Jonah Yu: 这应该是12，耶稣12个使徒里面唯一一个有坟墓的，在考古上唯一一个能知道他最具体的，死在什么地方的一个人，
Jonah Yu: 那这个人在耶稣升天以后，他就去了印度传福音，
Jonah Yu: 所以在第一世纪的时候就有很多人，
Jonah Yu: 很多在印度的人信了耶稣，
Jonah Yu: 所以很多的印度人，直到如今，他们的信
Jonah Yu: 就是百家姓的那个姓，他们的姓就姓多嘛。
Jonah Yu: 然后耶稣在第一世纪也有非常多的见证人。
Jonah Yu: 那今天我们读的这一个故事，其实就在讲说耶稣在当时的时代，
Jonah Yu: 有多少的影响力和有多少的见证人，
Jonah Yu: 我们可以看见耶稣的福音在当时已经传得非常的广。其实那个时候耶稣来到地上，他开始传天国的福音，还没有那么久，才刚开始的时候，他的影响力其实是非常大的。
Jonah Yu: 哎呀，第一个原因当然是因为太多人有需要了。
Jonah Yu: 这些人都是带着自己生活中最艰难的问题。来到耶稣的面前，
Jonah Yu: 我们现在每个人最艰难的问题都不一样，
Jonah Yu: 甚至有很多的艰难的问题，已经不是生理上的，也不是经济物质上的，
Jonah Yu: 而是内心里的。
Jonah Yu: 但我们可以看见
Jonah Yu: 这些人，许多人从家里里跟随她，这里面有
Jonah Yu: 有灾并
Jonah Yu: 有被污鬼附的
Jonah Yu: 这些人带着他们自己的需要来到耶稣的面前，耶稣都愿意帮助他们
Jonah Yu: 治愈他们治好了许多的人。
Jonah Yu: 这个故事不是告诉我们说耶稣是让人心想事成，有求必应，就是
Jonah Yu: 耶稣到地上来，他没有站在那个高山上面宣告说，从现在开始，
Jonah Yu: 所有这块土地上的人再也不会生病了，所有人所有人的病都好了。
Jonah Yu: 耶稣没有这么讲，耶稣是非常朴实的来到地上，当别人拥挤他的时候，
Jonah Yu: 他还要找一只船跑道，海面上其实那个是个湖，不是海。
Jonah Yu: 他跑到这个湖面上，也就是说，他在地上的时候，
Jonah Yu: 他是以完完全全是以一个人的身份来接近和他接触的每一个人，
Jonah Yu: 而每一个来到他面前的人。
Jonah Yu: 当这个人的生命当中有真正的需要最大的难处的时候，耶稣帮助他们，
Jonah Yu: 我们要想像一下当时的交通不是很方便的。
Jonah Yu: 耶稣在加利利湖这一个地方，
Jonah Yu: 现在这一些人要从哪里来，要从犹大
Jonah Yu: 犹大，就是以现在以色列的最南面跟
Jonah Yu: 几乎接近埃及的那个地方交犹大，耶路撒冷在以以色列的最难免
Jonah Yu: 移土满约旦河外就是现在的约旦，约旦和以色列是接壤的，
Jonah Yu: 泰尔西顿也叫翻译成推罗西顿是以色列的最北面
Jonah Yu: 正北方，靠西靠近地中海的地方，应该是现在的黎巴嫩。
Jonah Yu: 也就是说，从以色列地的最南面
Jonah Yu: 乃至到外邦的地方，就是那些人都已经不是以色列人对
Jonah Yu: 都来到耶稣面前来到加里底湖的边上，
Jonah Yu: 这么多人都来找耶稣，说明耶稣被宣传的极为的广泛，影响力非常的大，
Jonah Yu: 这种话是不能乱写的，这是真的得有
Jonah Yu: 目击者，有见证人，有历史学家考察这个事，那对于当时的人来讲，咳咳
Jonah Yu: 生病的话是一件大事，因为医疗非常的不发达，
Jonah Yu: 人的平均年龄只有30岁，40岁，非常的正常，
Jonah Yu: 所以只要家里面有人生病，外商内伤，传染病，感染，这些现代医学
Jonah Yu: 是可以处理的事，当时的人统统都处理不了，所以很多人种地的时候，
Jonah Yu: 脚被这个荆棘被木刺杀了，就有可能丢性命，一个人得了传染病，
Jonah Yu: 那一个村的人都有可能死掉这疾病对于疾病对于
Jonah Yu: 当时的人来讲是生命当中非常非常大的威胁，王公贵族
Jonah Yu: 都逃不了死于急症的这种灾难，特别这个翻译圣经的人很有意思，
Jonah Yu: 他这里讲，凡有灾病的，你看到没有反有灾，并的，他没有写凡生病的，
Jonah Yu: 因为灾和病是两件事
Jonah Yu: 和和本是圣经，不是中国人把圣经从英文翻译过来。
Jonah Yu: 我们现在读的这个中文圣经的版本是洋人，葡萄牙人
Jonah Yu: 在光绪年间来到中国。
Jonah Yu: 清啊清清碗溪光绪年间，也就是离现在大概120几年，
Jonah Yu: 130年的时间，到了中国之后学了中文，借着一些中国人的帮助，
Jonah Yu: 把圣经从希伯来文和希腊文翻译过来，所以这里翻译的灾病，
Jonah Yu: 他指的还不只是一般的生病这个灾啊，是一个非常强烈的用词
Jonah Yu: 就讲到这个病非常非常的严重，就好像这个人得了大灾难一样。
Jonah Yu: 这里讲的这个情形就是这个世界上，
Jonah Yu: 不管是在犹太地也好，还是在外邦的，不信神的，不信神的拜偶像的不拜偶像的每一个人，不是说每一个人吧。许许多多人的身上都有那一个灾病，是他们非常恐惧，非常害怕，而且自己没有办法胜过的。
Jonah Yu: 他描写的就是这样的一个情景，
Jonah Yu: 当他们听见说我现在生命中有这么大的问题，我完全没有能力去抵抗，
Jonah Yu: 没有办法去解决，我现在可以去找耶稣。
Jonah Yu: 另外一群人被污鬼附著。
Jonah Yu: 那我不知道我们中间多少人以前一直从前面我听过来的，
Jonah Yu: 我讲过这个事情，当圣经里面讲到被污鬼附着的时候，
Jonah Yu: 指的是，这一个世界上有一些的力量是无形的对你看不见它的来源，
Jonah Yu: 你也不知道他的工作方法，
Jonah Yu: 而人不得不在这一个影响力底下被他愚弄。
Jonah Yu: 在那个影响力底下生活。
Jonah Yu: 在当时，有一些人会被那个污鬼搞得非常的疯癫，胡言乱语
Jonah Yu: 得很多的，这个看上去像精神疾病一样的这个表现，
Jonah Yu: 那得灾病的和被污鬼附的。
Jonah Yu: 用我们现在的话来讲，他在描述一个什么情形呢？
Jonah Yu: 就是我们生命当中有一个极大的问题是把我们带进死亡里面，
Jonah Yu: 而我们是没有办法解决的，所以得那些灾病的人，
Jonah Yu: 他们这个灾病会加速一个人的死亡，每个人都要救自己的命。
Jonah Yu: 我们只是医疗条件非常的发达，现在的营养都跟得上，
Jonah Yu: 现在的环境比当时好，所以我们可以相对来讲延缓自己的死亡。
Jonah Yu: 但是这个仍然对每一个人来讲，它是一个灾病，
Jonah Yu: 一个人现在健康不会永远健康。
Jonah Yu: 一个人现在顺利，不会永远顺利的
Jonah Yu: 一个人，现在不去考虑死亡的问题，你不可能永远不考虑的，
Jonah Yu: 只是很多时候人自己骗自己。
Jonah Yu: 那当人真的觉得我的生命当中有一个面对死亡的极大的挑战，
Jonah Yu: 那福音。数据告诉你，你可以找耶稣，
Jonah Yu: 也有很多人得了病，去医院看看，不好
Jonah Yu: 看了，中西医看不好，去看中医，
Jonah Yu: 中医也看不好之后，你要怎么办呢？
Jonah Yu: 那很多人就去找偏方，那很多人都找过偏方，偏方，没有用就去练气功，
Jonah Yu: 气功没有用，我不知道大家怎么办呢？
Jonah Yu: 但无论如何，很多举自己觉得自己非常顽强的人，
Jonah Yu: 当疾病威胁到他生命的时候，
Jonah Yu: 他还是会去寻求一些他曾经根本看不上的，想都没有去想过的方法
Jonah Yu: 来试试看。
Jonah Yu: 这么多人来到耶稣的面前，
Jonah Yu: 很多很多人都是抱着试试看的态度，
Jonah Yu: 但是耶稣治好了他们的灾病，
Jonah Yu: 耶稣赶出去了，他们身上的污鬼。
Jonah Yu: 有的人在这个世界里被金钱的力量牢牢的控制住，有的人被
Jonah Yu: 情欲的力量牢牢控制住有的人被名誉的力量牢牢控制住了，
Jonah Yu: 也就是说他做什么事情，就是
Jonah Yu: 不是因为他有什么坏心啊，我们讲的还不是道德上的问题，
Jonah Yu: 我想的是，这个人的思想就是按照金钱多少的标准，名誉多少的标准，
Jonah Yu: 情欲是否得到满足的标准在那里生活，他觉得这个是自由的，
Jonah Yu: 其实这是被一个力量来控制，
Jonah Yu: 而这个力量，要确定他将来就慢慢的步入死亡当中，让他因为有这个力量在背后控制的时候让他可以，现在不要去想死亡的事情，不要去想永恒的事情，
Jonah Yu: 现在过得好就好了，这不是自由，这是被控制的，被一种能力所控制。
Jonah Yu: 对对对，这就是前面这段故事所描写的，对很多人
Jonah Yu: 应该是每一个人在我们生命当中都是对于生命的延续是有需要的，
Jonah Yu: 人总有不能抵挡的灾病人往往会被一些力量所控制，
Jonah Yu: 这些都是人需要得到释放，得到需要解救的地方，所以他们来找耶稣，
Jonah Yu: 那在这个故事里面，还有另外一段
Jonah Yu: 就是耶稣在遇到这么多的人
Jonah Yu: 几百个，我想大概不止几百个，成百上千的人，
Jonah Yu: 上万的人，后面有故事，我们讲到说会有上万的人来找一首耶稣，的确
Jonah Yu: 尽他在地上的。作为一个人，尽他所有的时间，尽他所能来帮助这些人。
Jonah Yu: 但是这些人的当中。
Jonah Yu: 很有意思的是，耶稣挑了12个人做他的门徒，
Jonah Yu: 那这12个人和其他所有的人非常的不一样，是因为从那一天开始，
Jonah Yu: 这12个人的生活就完全改变了
Jonah Yu: 前面去找耶稣的这些人，他们的病好了鬼被赶走了，
Jonah Yu: 他们就回到自己的老家过他们原来的日子。
Jonah Yu: 但是这12个人自从遇见耶稣之后，
Jonah Yu: 他们跟耶稣是吃也在一起住，也在一起，干事也在一起，
Jonah Yu: 在圣经里面福音书里面有很多的研读圣经的人去做过一个调查，考察
Jonah Yu: 就是耶稣在地上这么长的时间，自从他选招门徒之后，
Jonah Yu: 大概有75%的时间，它的所有时间里面有75%的时间。以上
Jonah Yu: 是跟门徒在一起。
Jonah Yu: 也就是说，耶稣在地上，他专门培养了一群人，是跟他紧密连接，
Jonah Yu: 传承他的使命，懂得他在说什么吗？
Jonah Yu: 关于天国的真理。耶稣是花了几年的时间，详详细细跟他们解释的，
Jonah Yu: 这就是门徒跟耶稣的关系，
Jonah Yu: 而不是其他那些人跟耶稣的关系。
Jonah Yu: 那换一句话说，所有来到耶稣的面前的人，里面
Jonah Yu: 有一些人是愿意跟随耶稣做耶稣的门徒的那门徒这个词，他的
Jonah Yu: 含义就是什么有一些人他愿意付代价，跟随耶稣
Jonah Yu: 门徒指的是什么呢？
Jonah Yu: 就是你不管是学刺绣的呀，学裁缝的呀，学木匠的呀，这种手一伙，
Jonah Yu: 那都是要徒弟跟师傅学的。
Jonah Yu: 徒弟跟师傅学很多年，住在师傅家里面，师傅要吃饭，给他做饭，
Jonah Yu: 师傅要干什么，扑睡觉，给他铺床，
Jonah Yu: 师傅家里面零零散散的杂伙做他干，但这个不是重点，
Jonah Yu: 重点是他看着师傅一举一动，怎么样的生活，怎么样做他的手艺，
Jonah Yu: 这个比这个师傅出去讲一堂讲座，给人家介绍一下这个手艺呀，
Jonah Yu: 那要来的精深了很多。
Jonah Yu: 在所有跟随耶稣的信耶稣的人里面有一些人是愿意付代价
Jonah Yu: 来跟随耶稣的
Jonah Yu: 那这些人，他们的生命就得到了极大的改变，一个是原来做渔夫的，
Jonah Yu: 现在不用做渔夫了，原来做渔夫的不做鱼腹，他不饿死吗？
Jonah Yu: 没有。我们没有看见任何一个门徒是饿死的门徒，后来都是寻到的，不是饿死的。
Jonah Yu: 啧但是做渔夫说一辈子做到最好，最有钱，产业最大的你还是渔夫，
Jonah Yu: 渔夫，所有的价值都在打鱼的上面，
Jonah Yu: 但是这个渔夫跟随耶稣之后，它的价值，他的影响力跟打鱼的
Jonah Yu: 不可同日而语人都希望自己生命当中可以产生价值，
Jonah Yu: 都希望自己可以被认可，而这个是做渔夫的人达不到的，
Jonah Yu: 这个认可是被神认可，这个价值是在永恒里面有价值，
Jonah Yu: 不是说现在一个人原来是在公司上班的，他没有什么价值，现在去做了一个牧师啊，他可以跟几百个人，几千个人，几万个人讲道啊，他现在有名了，不是这个，
Jonah Yu: 这些渔夫，到后来他们死的时候都没那么有名的影响力有限的，
Jonah Yu: 当然后面人把它吹捧起来，那是另外一回事，那他们真正的价值
Jonah Yu: 是永恒，里面的价值，是他们一辈子不是靠打鱼可以得来的？
Jonah Yu: 对啊咳。
Jonah Yu: 第二种人雅各约翰这两个人的名字叫范奇尼，就是雷子的意思，
Jonah Yu: 那这俩为什么叫雷子呢，就是暴脾气，他们俩原来也是打鱼的，这两个人
Jonah Yu: 脾气非常暴躁，他们在跟随耶稣的这个道路上，有人说有人不跟随耶稣
Jonah Yu: 不服，不信约翰就跟耶稣说什么，
Jonah Yu: 求你从天上降火下来，烧死他们。
Jonah Yu: 耶稣跟他讲，说，我来这里是要怜悯人的，我是要救人的，我不是要把人烧死的，
Jonah Yu: 你搞清楚好不好，这说明约翰这个人的脾气是巨暴躁，
Jonah Yu: 动不动就跟人家吹胡子瞪眼睛。
Jonah Yu: 然而我们看圣经的后面，约翰
Jonah Yu: 写了约翰福音。约翰写了约翰一二，三书，约翰学了启示录，我们完全看不出这个作者，
Jonah Yu: 他是一个雷子
Jonah Yu: 约翰这个人在12个使徒里面是活得最久的。他活到快活到100岁。
Jonah Yu: 他在人生最晚年的时候还被发配到边江海岛去流放，
Jonah Yu: 后来还回到了以色列。
Jonah Yu: 我们看他晚年的这个著作是一个何等温柔，谦卑，有为父的心肠的一个人，
Jonah Yu: 他讲什么都是娓娓道来，语重心长，让人心服口服，
Jonah Yu: 也就是说跟随耶稣的人，他不但是他的使命和价值，改变了
Jonah Yu: 他的性格，也改变了他的生命里面那些败坏的特质渐渐地消去，
Jonah Yu: 让人羡慕的知道的，好的品质，慢慢的成长，这个就是约翰，
Jonah Yu: 我们之前也读到过马太马太原来是个税吏，
Jonah Yu: 是在社会上面最被犹太人瞧不起的，那他自己又没有办法，因为税里很赚钱，
Jonah Yu: 他生活在这种两难之中口碑又不好，他又不愿意放弃他的财路。
Jonah Yu: 当他跟随耶稣之后，他发现colby也没有那么重要，财路也没有那么重要。
Jonah Yu: 他后来写下马太福音给我们看见什么是重要天国是最重要的，
Jonah Yu: 他放下了地上的
Jonah Yu: 他觉得重要的东西，让他两难的东西，他选择了第三条路，走天国的路。
Jonah Yu: 这里面也提到过多玛多玛，我刚才讲过了，多玛是一直怀疑耶稣
Jonah Yu: 耶稣复活之后，多玛怀疑说耶稣怎么会活了？你们不要胡说八道，
Jonah Yu: 他连耶稣复活以后都怀疑对哈哈，
Jonah Yu: 但是他却最后在印度寻到他在祷告的时候废物罗马人刺死在
Jonah Yu: 他祷告的那个教堂的地下室里面还有一个叫的西门
Jonah Yu: 那分锐党的意思就是用现在的话来讲就是恐怖分子，
Jonah Yu: 他们非常不服罗马人的统治，
Jonah Yu: 他们非常不喜欢罗马日用这傀儡的政权，他们愤世嫉俗，
Jonah Yu: 你说这你，你把它说的大了，叫恐怖分子说，小一点就是愤青，对
Jonah Yu: 张口闭口就是意识形态呀，你们，我们啊这样的一群人，
Jonah Yu: 现在他跟随了耶稣之后地上的政治在他的心里不会再有烙印，
Jonah Yu: 这是很奇妙的一件事，对，
Jonah Yu: 哎，有很多人开口闭口就是什么伊朗啊，美国啊，中国啊，日本啊，
Jonah Yu: 历史啊，屈辱啊，自由啊，民主啊很多人非常非常喜欢谈这些这个罪，他
Jonah Yu: 对他自己的自尊和价值感带来很大的爆棚，
Jonah Yu: 那做到极端，就是这个分。锐党就是恐怖分子就成了愤青了。
Jonah Yu: 但是当他遇见耶稣之后，他能够放下自己所有的政治观点，他得自由了。
Jonah Yu: 地上人文给他带来的捆绑不存在了。
Jonah Yu: 还有一个卖耶稣的加略人犹大，这故事很有名啊大家都知道，犹大卖耶稣犹大是个叛徒，
Jonah Yu: 耶稣是神啊，他从第一天就知道犹大一定会卖他。
Jonah Yu: 但是我们纵观所有福音，书里面讲到耶稣跟犹大的故事，
Jonah Yu: 我们会看见耶稣对犹大是真的非常非常的好，
Jonah Yu: 最后犹大去卖耶稣的时候由大叔
Jonah Yu: 跟别人讲，说，别人问犹大，说，我们知道这么多人里面哪个是耶稣？犹大说，我现在去跟谁亲嘴，亲嘴是他们当时的打招呼的方式，我跟谁去亲嘴，你就知道那个是耶稣，我跟他亲完就把他抓了，
Jonah Yu: 不要抓别人，不要抓错了。
Jonah Yu: 当耶稣知道犹大来跟他亲嘴，是为了卖他的时候，耶稣仍然跟他非常
Jonah Yu: 亲热的，真诚的清嘴
Jonah Yu: 一辈子，耶稣对犹大是非常非常好，只是最后犹大选择了把耶稣给卖了。
Jonah Yu: 对啊，我不能说我们都是犹大，
Jonah Yu: 但是我们真的不希望说，有这么好的一位主，他对我们充满着恩惠
Jonah Yu: 充满着怜悯，而我们为了自己很多的私欲想要让他消失
Jonah Yu: 基督徒啊，不要跟我们讲关于耶稣的事，我不想知道，
Jonah Yu: 这就是要耶稣消失嘛，耶稣对我再好，跟我没关系，不要来烦我，
Jonah Yu: 我们可能没有犹大那么恶劣，做出这样的很卑劣的事情，
Jonah Yu: 但是我们多少都有可能有这种心态。
Jonah Yu: 我们不觉得信耶稣得永生是个什么太了不起的事情，
Jonah Yu: 他把耶稣卖了，才卖30块钱，一个人一个月的工资，
Jonah Yu: 有的人为了一个月的工资，一年的工资，十年的工资，
Jonah Yu: 宁愿不要生命当中给我们带来永恒的好处的最好的礼物，
Jonah Yu: 那是非常可惜的事情。
Jonah Yu: 好我今天的分享就到这里。
Paul 盛: 好，谢谢谢谢markov弟兄，我不知道大家有什么问题，没有
Paul 盛: 有问题，我们可以提啊。
Liping He: 我有一个问题。
Paul 盛: 好，谢谢。
Liping He: 就是那个耶稣的这12个门徒，里面的约翰
Liping He: 是写那个约翰福音，里面的约翰还是写后面那个约翰一书，二书和三书里面的约翰啊。
Jonah Yu: 约翰圣经里写圣经的只有一个，约翰，就是这同一个约翰，
Jonah Yu: 他写了约翰福音约翰一，二，三书和启示录。他一共写了五本。
Liping He: 好的好的，我还没读呢。
Paul 盛: 好的，谢谢。
Paul 盛: 没关系，我们可以以后一起读，
Liping He: 好的。
Paul 盛: 好，那如果大家没有别的问题。我想
Paul 盛: 今天因为这个信息讲到门徒哈，我觉得因为马，可我们也非常感恩马可弟兄愿意来美洲来跟我们分享神的话，
Paul 盛: 那他因为他跟我在一个教会啊。然后我也知道他自己就是
Paul 盛: 把自己单单归给神的
Paul 盛: 就是是全身心服事，神的他就他的工作就是服事神，
Paul 盛: 那我想刚才讲到他讲到这个门徒和耶稣
Paul 盛: 在一起的时间，我想马克，就我自己自己判断，我也我也没有统计哈那他，
Paul 盛: 每天在省的工作上付出的时间，我想应该是
Paul 盛: 差不多也是那个比例吧，所以我们也特别的感谢谢mark弟兄，
Paul 盛: 然后我们另外有两个报告啊，一个就是因为我们下周呢？
Paul 盛: 这个周末美国就下令时了，那我们从下周开始的聚会就是国内的
Paul 盛: 时间就会往前提了，就相当于我们这边就变成了8.1刻。对吧？
Paul 盛: 好吧。然后大家就知道一下第二件事情就是。
Paul 盛: 我们特别谢谢jen源。他已经帮我们做了一个
Paul 盛: 网网址网站啊然后呢，把
Paul 盛: 马可弟兄，我们的从第一次聚会以来的录音都可以上传到上面，
Paul 盛: 这样以后我们新加入的，或者你随时想听的，可以登录到这个网站上去去听这些信息，
Paul 盛: 然后我们可能还没有完全调试完，调试完了以后呢？会给大家发布。就是特别感谢谢郑源的这样的，
Paul 盛: 有这样的性来帮助我们
Paul 盛: 好，我们如果没有别的事情，我们请南方姐妹给我们做一个结束祷告吧，谢谢。
Lanfang Liu: 好的。
Lanfang Liu: 亲爱的主耶稣，非常感谢你让我们弟兄姊妹能够在线上相聚，利用一个小时的时间学习你的话语，也非常感谢你通过你的
Lanfang Liu: 通过马可弟兄的口能够讲述你的话语，让我们通过你的话语认识你，亲近你主啊，也非常也也求你
Lanfang Liu: 用你的圣灵充满我们。你的话语不仅是给我们的知识，更需要给我们智慧，让我们有更强的辨别力卓啊，
Lanfang Liu: 求你用圣灵带领我们，把你的话住在我们心里，让我们活出
Lanfang Liu: 你的样子，变成我们生活，把你的话语在我们的生活，行为，工作当中充分的体现出来，让你成为我们里面的人心中的心。生命中的生命活著
Lanfang Liu: 就像歌中所唱的一样，活着不再是我，乃是基督成为我们的生命。在我里面活着以上祷告，奉主耶稣的名囚阿们。
Paul 盛: 妹好，谢谢谢谢大家晚安，我们下周见。
HUAWEI PLR-AL00: 来看这样。